dans ce reportage je vous emmène dans
l'une des ambulences les plus chaudes de
France le match entre les lycées
Versailles Ginette Sainte-Geneviève et
hoche c'est parti
ma jambe chat
incroyable commission énorme ça fait une
semaine qu'on chante tous les soirs dans
le rêve bien sûr 600 personnes ce soir
voire plus Ginette
c'est incroyable je vous dis
c'est sûr qu'on va gagner
[Musique]
vraiment écraser Ginette je sais pas
s'il y a plus de bruit mais c'est
toujours aussi émouvant
c'est complètement fou on le savait on
espérait
chaque année on est surpris et on est
heureux après plusieurs minutes ça se
répond les tribunes s'embrasent au
moment de l'entrée des joueurs Hoche
tenant du titre veut décrocher sa
troisième victoire mais pour l'instant
c'est Ginette qui mène 14 à 2 Ginette
Hoche c'est avant tout un show les
organisateurs ont voulu créer un
événement unique en France au programme
concours de dunk football freestyle DJ
et un concert de deux chanteuses une de
H en rouge et une de Ginette en bleu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
également proposé des chorégraphies
acrobatiques un spectacle répété depuis
la rentrée
[Musique]
normal c'est des jeunes joueurs et c'est
pas leur métier mais mais c'est
spécialité très intéressant
[Applaudissements]
et le match se termine par une victoire
de Ginette sur le score de 47 à 38 face
à Auch au bilan des confrontations ça
fait 15 à 2 pour Ginette et pour la fête
on a été très prolifique on a été plus
politique
la défaite on l'accepte la défaite on
l'accepte mais honnêtement c'était
formidable mais l'année prochaine on a
gagné l'année dernière alors laisse la
victoire voilà c'est comme ça c'est la
vie mais bon c'est pas grave on garde le
sourire on va boire là maintenant
c'était génial on est hyper content il y
avait une super ambiance et merci aux
joueurs et merci à la mort aussi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça fait de remporter ce
choc là je suis hyper heureux j'avoue
que tout le match est un peu douté parce
que c'était serré je pense qu'on a eu un
temps fort au 4e carton avec mentalement
il y a un truc qui a changé on a eu un
ou deux tiers et la mentalement on s'est
dit on va le faire on va le faire et là
là c'est parti donc je pense que c'est
ça ouais donc je suis hyper heureux
on a gagné mais c'était surtout une
fabuleuse soirée pleine de de belles
choses une parenthèse étoilée dans un
monde où les élèves font des au travail
beaucoup je perds les mots excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
rendez-vous l'année prochaine pour une
18e édition le public en redemande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]